et pour en parler nous sommes avec eux
julia poiret porte parole de génépi une
association qui milite pour le
décloisonnement des prisons julia
poirier bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en direct sur rt france
la france a donc été condamnée pour
l'état de ses prisons
ce n'est pas la première fois que les
prisons françaises sont montrés du doigt
non c'est pas la première fois alors le
système interne judiciaire que ce soit
administratif le conseil d'état ou alors
le conseil constitutionnel ont beaucoup
de mal à reconnaître l'état des prisons
et quand ils le reconnaissent comme ça a
été le cas avec le conseil d'état
il se déclare en même temps incapable de
donner des ordres pour la gestion des
prisons donc en général les
condamnations viennent plutôt de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme comme
ce fut le cas hier
et évidemment les condamnation par la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme ne
sont pas rares y en a plus d'une
trentaine moment ils sont cons à 37,38
son père le comte et donc voilà pour
nous en cela la décision de faire n'est
pas exceptionnel et l' alerte et tiré en
fait depuis des dizaines d'années qu'est
ce qui est montré du doigt très
précisément c'est la surpopulation dans
les prisons comment ça se passe
concrètement les détenus sont à 2 3 dans
une cellule qui ne doit finalement
accueillir qu'une seule personne c'est
ça le problème
alors la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme a notamment effectivement pointé
du doigt le surpeuplement ont parfois
appelée la surpopulation carcérale
effectivement dans les maisons d'arrêt
où il ya 60%
en fait il ya des chiffres qui
représente à la fois dans les maisons
d'arrêt les personnes prévenues
c'est-à-dire en attente de leur procès
en détention provisoire et les personnes
condamnées à des peines de moins de deux
ans et donc en fait c'est là où il ya
tation population effectivement parce
que ce sont les plus gros taux
d'incarcération après un jugement mais
pour nous le problème il ne faut pas
raisonner en termes de surpopulation
mais en termes de sueur incarcération
car le problème n'est pas le manque de
place comme je le disais il ya quelques
heures dans le figaro mais
le manque de le trop-plein de jugement à
des peines d'emprisonnement
les juges incarcère trop alors justement
la ministre de la justice répond en
disant qu'elle dit compter sur sa
réforme de l'échelle des peines c'est à
dire plus de peines de prison lorsqu'on
est condamné à 1 mois et ménager les
peines de prison lorsque ces des peines
de moins de 6 mois d'emprisonnement
c'est un bon début pour ou un nom pour
moi c'est un rétropédalage parce que les
peines demande en moi alors certes on
peut les supprimer mais en fait ce qui
se passe c'est qu'il ya très peu de
peine de moins d'un mois qu'ils sont
prononcés dans les faits est sûre je
veux condamner un temps court il
condamnera à un mois une semaine à deux
mois à trois mois donc ça va pas
réellement faire qui est vraiment le
personnes enfermées et sur l'aménagement
peine en fait l'aménagement de peine il
existe déjà
avant 2014 on pouvait aménagé tout plein
de maximum un an de prison prononcée on
pouvait la transformer en une autre
peine qui fait partie plutôt de
l'arsenal des peines alternatives en
2014 la loi taubira est venue prolonger
cette possibilité aux peines jusqu'à
deux ans de prison
et aujourd'hui ce que nous propose le
gouvernement est le projet porté par
madame belloubet c'est de rétropédaler à
avant 2014 et de prévoir cette
possibilité uniquement pour les peines
d'un an donc dans les faits c'est
hypocrite parce que ça va mener à plus
de condamnations fermes et plus
d'exécution de peine
donc plus de personnes en prison en
cliqua est ce que la justice européenne
un véritable pouvoir pour faire pression
sur la politique française dans ce
domaine là son pouvoir il est financier
on voit qu'elle a condamné la france à
payer des amendes de plusieurs centaines
de milliers d'euros
mais au-delà de ça ça fait des dizaines
d'années que la france est condamnée par
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
il n'y a aucun changement concret étant
donné qu'en fait la prison c'est un
système c'est pas juste une bâtisse avec
des murs dans lequel il ya des rares
c'est un système qui se
nourri des politiques pénales qu'ils
sont à la fois législatives policière et
judiciaire
et au bout de la chaîne on à la prison
mais en fait ce qu'il faut voir c'est
que tout ça est un système c'est un
processus et tant qu'il n'y a pas de
réelle volonté de remettre en cause ce
système qu'elle enfermement tel qu'il
est pensé depuis le xviiie siècle il y
aura aucun changement véritable
justement pour conclure qu'elles sont
vous les changements que vous attendez
aujourd'hui alors le génépi en tant
qu'association se positionne aujourd'hui
contre l'enfermement contre toute forme
d'enfermement que ce soit à la fois dans
les prisons dans les centres de
rétention administrative pour les
étrangers dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques dans les centres
d'enfermement pour ménard et j'en passe
nous sommes contre l'enfermement et nous
proposons d'apporter sur le débat public
la question de la prison peut-on s'en
passer nous on répond oui il faut s'en
passer et qu'est-ce qu'on fait sans
prison c'est à nous de réfléchir
collectivement avec les pouvoirs publics
sur qu'est ce qu'on fait si on ne veut
pas de prison les prisons la prison
aujourd'hui elle tue on refuse la prison
comme il ya eu des combats pour
l'abolition de la peine de mort au sol
pour l'abolition de la prison merci
julia pourrait d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je rappelle que vous êtes
porte-parole du génépi ile de france